Open.
Open a door and it opens all the others.
Open a mind and see what happens next.
No great thing, no beautiful invention, was created in a vacuum.
It happens when we leave our comfort zone and come together.
...embrace faiths, cultures, disabilities, differences,...
...embrace races, ages, ideologies, personalities,...
...creating a tool or device nobody saw coming.
Humanity is plural, not singular.
The best way the world works is everybody in, nobody out.
So, who we're made of is everyone,...
...differences not just celebrated but essential.
Many more women in charge, equal pay for equal work, everywhere.
A new generation of Apple, more diverse than the one that came before.
Open is not just who we are, but what we believe as a company...
...because humanity isn't singular.
It's plural.
The truth is we don't see things the same.
The power is, we don't see things the same.